welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Star Wars Episode nine the rise
of Skywalker faces the difficult task of
tying together nine films a trilogy of
trilogies aka nonology a term that
sounds like what I said I majored in
when I didn't pick a major yet majoring
in neurology yeah based on the two
trailers that have been released so far
cryptic clues if hinted at waste
director JJ Abrams might do that and it
appears to center around the return of
the Emperor sheev Palpatine aka Darth
Sidious the evil mastermind who is
behind everything from episodes one
through six and perhaps even Episode
nine Palpatine's iconic cackle echoed
through the first trailer in the d23
footage his voice croaks
yes add this to a number of other clues
like what looked like the ruins of the
second Death Star essentially the grave
of Palpatine plus the appearance of a
massive fleet of old-school imperial
star destroyers plus the vision of an
evil ray with a dual wield maul style
red saber plus some lingering questions
about Ray's lineage plus they speculated
about plot threads from literary
material all of these things have
suggested that there may be a conspiracy
at work to rescue these Star Wars
franchise from the apathy many felt
after the last Jedi in solo with a
shocking finale that connects all the
dots we and others have speculated on
connections between Palpatine and Rey
and a number of very entertaining
theories but with recent reveals from
the d23 footage in the Mandalorian let
us dive even deeper into this and thank
you to privacy comm for sponsoring this
episode more details later how they can
help protect your online spending as I
mentioned I am hardly the first to
theorize that there must be more to the
explanation we got about Rey's parentage
in the last Jedi they would nobody there
are filthy junk treasures so do you
offer drinking money yeah okay a number
of others have suggested that
Palpatine's resurgence in the rise of
Skywalker could mean a revised
explanation for Rey's lineage because we
are no strangers to magical thinking and
we don't like being told to forget about
everything we love so spit out the green
milk I pick up the damn lightsaber one
possible explanation could have been
hinted at in Palpatine's story of Darth
Plagueis the wise of players
the Dark Lord of the Sith so powerful
and so wise he could use the Force to
influence the midi-chlorians to create
life unfortunately
he taught his apprentice everything he
knew then his apprentice killed him in
his sleep and we found out later that
plagues his apprentice was indeed
Sidious
that means Sidious could have used this
midi-chlorian manipulation for genetic
experiments like in the legends book
dark empire Palpatine actually
resurrects as a clone body transferring
his spirit from clone to clone and
eventually Han and Leia's infant son
Anakin but this storyline is obviously
no longer considered canon however the
concept of cloning obviously still is
with the Republic's army in attack of
the clones being composed of clones of
Jango Fett engineered on Kamino we also
know from the novel shattered Empire
that Palpatine arranged a contingency
plan called operation cinder in the
event of his death carried out by
messenger droids with recordings of his
face the order was to ravage thousands
of planetary surfaces across the galaxy
via climate manipulation from satellites
essentially it was a if I don't get it
to burn it all down strategy actually
the game Star Wars Battlefront 2
expanded on operation cinder with a
showdown at the jakku Observatory a
place on the plancha coup that contains
Sith artifacts in star maps to the
Unknown Regions it is possible that Rey
could be part of that abandoned
contingency plan like a genetic
experiment by Palpatine left with jakku
junk traders who abandoned her but I
believe based on new details that this
conspiracy goes even deeper when that
d23 trailer dropped most were buzzing
over a wide range Darth Maul yes it's a
head scratcher but even more mysterious
to me was the appearance of a fleet of
imperial star destroyers if you look
closely they were is di class from the
original trilogy era from the force
awakens onward the Imperial Navy was
supposed to be wiped out replaced by the
first order and if the first order had a
fleet of old-school imperial star
destroyers you wouldn't known about it
like they they would have used it
probably the book aftermath empires end
details the events after the battle of
jakku in which the fragments of the
Imperial Navy retreats to the Unknown
Regions on the Star Destroyer the
Eclipse with Grand Admiral Sloane and
Jen
Huck's training child soldiers to
rebuild the empire saying that this will
be their first wait for it order now
sometime thereafter Snoke came in
control of the first order apparently he
was around the Unknown Regions
researching and learning the ways of the
force on his own and in the last Jedi
novelization we find out that Snoke came
to control the first order by saving
them for many enemies apparently
Palpatine could sense Snoke from the
Unknown Regions while Palpatine was
still alive but he supposedly didn't
know what Snoke was up to yet but
recently we learned that the series the
Mandalorian will reveal more about the
origin of the first order that story
will take place around with the first
order forms between Return of the Jedi
and the force awakens the series is
premiering in November and that places
the Mandalorian season to coincide right
with the rise of Skywalker's released in
late December so what if the new detail
about the origin of the first order was
another layer to operation cinder in
which Snoke remember was a wealthy snob
who drapes himself in jewelry and golden
bathrobes what if this guy was used by
Palpatine as a puppet with snoke's vast
financial resources going toward
rebuilding the Imperial Navy in secret
this fleet of stardestroyers could carry
on Palpatine's operations Synder plan to
devastate planet surfaces and in the d23
trailer we see blasts ripping up terrain
that could be part of cinder I mean
folks Snoke had to be a puppet right you
could see the seam in either way you
could definitely use that corpse as a
puppet now I'm a joke of a villain but
why now you might ask why would
Palpatine's posthumous orders go dormant
after the battle of jakku and then why
would he let Snoke in the first order
run the show for a whole generation and
then only now come back for the final
chapter this series before I get to that
thank you to privacy comm for sponsoring
this breakdown privacy comm is a free
service that lets you buy things online
using virtual burner cards instead of
your actual credit card information so
you know you don't end up with a charge
on your credit card for like a freaking
fleet of stardestroyers you know someone
had to pay for those and in addition to
protecting your information when you
shop online privacy also protects you
from getting double charged for one of
your million content subscriptions so
for example I have set up an account
with privacy linked by bank account and
I'm creating a one-time card to papery
YouTube red subscription I'm gonna set
the limit of the card
for $1 so I can just try out YouTube
bread for free for a month so when I set
up my YouTube red subscription I will
use this dummy card number that privacy
auto-generated and later say I'd forget
to like cancel the subscription as we
all do rather than the services being
like I can feel your focus custom UI my
time something you don't want I will get
notified when privacy blocks YouTube
from charging me the full amount for the
next month because this burner cards one
dollar limit was maxed out keeping me
safe and yeah this works for everything
it's so easy and again it's free and
we're gonna make this deal even better
for you guys first time customers who
sign up with privacy calm slash new rock
stars will get five dollars off their
first purchase with privacy calm just go
to privacy calm slash new rock stars
that's PRI BAC y comm slash any wroc KS
t ARS to get five dollars off your first
purchase now so how and why does
Palpatine return the rise of Skywalker
well we know this movie will revisit the
ruins of the Death Star with Rey and
kylo battling along the wreckage of what
looks like the second Death Star's
trench perhaps this return to
Palpatine's grave site awakens the
spirit of the old fifth Lord and he
could reveal a deeper truth about Rey's
lineage perhaps the theories are true
that Rey was actually genetically
engineered by Palpatine that the endless
reflections of her in the SIF cave in
the last Jedi with subtle differences
among each actually reflected her
existence as one of many clone copies
and the reason that when she asked to
see her parents the reflection merely
showed two shadow figures coming
together to form herself or if you
really wanna go bonkers
the reason Luke's lightsaber called to
Rey could be that she was engineered
from midi-chlorian filled DNA of luke
skywalker's severed hand scooped up from
Cloud City a fingernail gets pulled off
and then boom he got a female clone
birthed in a test tube in the jakku
observatory Palpatine's plan could be to
manipulate and tempt Rey hitting her and
kylo against each other as rival
candidates to succeed him in his legacy
that image of Rey with the dual wield
lightsaber could be a vision conjured by
Palpatine spirit inspired by his past
apprentice Darth Maul match ad imagine
yourself with a weapon that befits
abilities actually the official
description of this moment in the
trailer was sneakily changed on the Star
Wars website from the vision of a Rey to
the sight of Rey
of a ray to me sounds like a dreamlike
projection of a ray like one of many
rays or the hypothetical ray a ray clone
chained up in a synthetic somewhere and
that freezing being changed suggests to
me that the previous wording might have
revealed too much and some poor bloggers
lost a hand but what form would
Palpatine taken this plan resurrected in
a new body as a ghost and happening
objects like Vader's mask maybe or could
his pre-recorded contingency plan emit
from a host droid the way his voice and
visit came from operation cinder
messenger droids
what droid would that be in the rise of
Skywalker well what droid has like Papa
teen been there the whole time the whole
time I think we caught him red-handed
folks
or should I say red eyed c-3po this nerd
built by the future Darth Vader himself
can't help but get cross-wired
it's his destiny his source code and in
the weeks leading up to Star Wars
Celebration last spring Threepio actor
anthony daniels tweeted a series of
cryptic garbled tweets that when decoded
rearranged into like a crummy commercial
tease for the event but what if those
garbled tweets themselves were hinting
at a deeper truth about Threepio in this
film one in which his CPU gets scrambled
by an external force as he becomes the
host of the ultimate ghost in the
machine
the latest advocate of a secret
operation unfolding under our noses for
decades to position the true Skywalker
successor to betray her legacy and dare
her to rise to meet the challenge if JJ
Abrams intends to hyper slice through
the negativity with a bombshell that
ties in the Skywalker legacy the mystery
of Rey's past and Snoke in the first
order all the prequel technobabble and
Palpatine's master plan perhaps the
answer is a total Gruber's what do you
think is Palpatine's plan in the rise of
Skywalker
and what total conspiracy should we
investigate next comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on twitter and
instagram at a boss and subscribe to new
rock stars for more breakdowns of
everything star wars and be sure to
subscribe to our star wars podcast feed
WikiLeaks
thank you for joining me and if anyone
wants to make a snow puppet for me I
will gladly feature him as a regular
host on this channel welcome back to the
rock stars I'm a huge letdown
[Music]